is that big that sell her off the punt
fake weight side with a great block
first block of the night for a shot
that's a great screen for the brooder
role to perfection
let's left first quarter heat ahead by
two Augustin pick and roll with Vukovich
keeps it at white side sends it three
rows deep good recognition to did not
leave Vukovich too early guys by staying
in between and then it's for Whiteside
crusher with the right hand this dunk of
the game a brilliant dish by the dragon
it has been a ragged story on this is
Whiteside I'm attaching to stuff from
China really nice feet yet again from
draaga CH in the court last year
[Applause]
Magruder's flopping Whiteside stuffing
to have an excellent connection standing
ovations
so Richardson gets the early rest and
wait as in there's about 26 minutes a
game of the first two oh man how much
better as McGruder gotten off the
dribble setting up Hassan Whiteside
calls for the screen gets it eight to
shoot
monk that's kidd-gilchrist Whiteside
spiking that one right into the Hornets
bench 16 to find response to New York's
14-nothing run amplifier nice block by
Whiteside
it's first to the game three down for
Whiteside in his 20 minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
whiteside it's a quick rub screen there
and the role by hasad and rodney draws
cancer just enough to be able to go up
top and give his son forward by these
trays in this cool kelly olynyk one side
what a nice setup by Kelly Olynyk as his
second assistant does a team getting
great play from their guards their
Center and their bench
this is Lillard nice wraparound bounce
to fight White's out right there kids
just picked up his first staff of the
Trailblazers eat lead by three first
touch nothing offensive end for
Whiteside his first shot is ain't done
drug it's drawing the big man Collins
zzs gonna get a shot potentially blocked
it just throws it to the front of the
rim on the double-team McGruder now
defending he'll white jackets
cauley-stein a little world the shot
that's his third block for the first
quarter he keeps hidden blood rebounds
and field goal percentage smartly never
done and BCC such a competitive leaves
aside Whiteside with both hands
comes up with his fourth block of the
first quarter I think the Sixers are not
as good without Belinelli here in the
[Applause]
looks they're doing it off the dribble
penetration justice Winslow deliver side
who continues to make himself available
with those nice hands to catch and
finish another block for Whiteside send
it back at hurdle and look at the sound
inside had a foot under the basket got
out to 18 feet to it screen by Whiteside
Winslow with four of a shot clock oh
nice dish yes every time off a great
play by Winslow Whiteside with his
second ferocious dunk of the game look
at the shoulder delivered by justice
Winslow bulb right there to create some
room and drops it off and how about that
with a little button right there hard
finish the heat hitting three of the
first four triples they've missed their
last whoa
[Applause]
first of week what we hope are many
Whiteside handed rejection on the shot
clock for cruder lobster right side well
done another lock connection between
Rodney and a side Joe Harris run at the
heart on that way another eight point
lead for Brooklyn McGruder mrs. white
side smash his home with shot clock
resets to 14 it was in for three
Whiteside pursues the rebound and
flushes it that is the white side you
love Dondre Drummond of Detroit Don he's
so instinctive with the way he can block
and bullish and he is an improving big
man we're tied at 52 636 left on the
third Whiteside turns and hammers it
down
big fella gettin it done strong post up
step across J rich delivering and here
comes a little thunder heat defense
playing very well the Bulls under twenty
nine percent shooting Whiteside gets his
first block of the game he leads the
league in over three game and he
finishes thank you will and Ruth will
see guys at halftime of the last 11
minutes of this game eat about square
the bowls 3210 Whiteside what a pot that
was Jean Whiteside has been using his
anticipation using his left hand Rudy's
a handful with his flank blocking shots
at the rim second game in a row the Heat
have just ten men available right side
go by he spanked that one that was for
his first block of the game haven't
turned in the corner looking for the LOB
there for Gobert he's one of their
better passers in a lot of space for
their team because of how they move and
what widen the floor Mitchell I would
keep her irate spite Hassan Whiteside
that's the second block tonight is 13
Hassan suffocating Donovan Mitch 28 year
old Holliday having his best season in
the NBA a decade into his career
Whiteside flying and finishing with a
two-handed dunk followed on five on the
shot clock
Wade nice pick-and-roll for a Whiteside
dunk in Wade sells this so well on a
dribble handoff fools everyone thinking
that he's gonna take the shot bucks old
five from downtown when he old for three
from the lambda3
Whiteside underneath some good old
cool basketball pick and roll for a
white shotgun versatility on display his
ability to make things happen
off the dribble McGruder's zigzagging
with a dribble flips it up every starter
scored and they've forced three
turnovers already good defensive
disposition Isaac had it blocked by
Whiteside who is an excellent job of
protecting their in Charlotte at number
six and the treatment number seven both
have 16 losses Whiteside hands on the
rim call for a technical foul Hampton
school here's the Hassan keeper right
here confusion on the Orlando's but on a
regular basis under first year head
coach Nick nurse Whiteside picks it off
the deck these deep adduction tremendous
straight that agility for Whiteside has
the rebound
the Raptors have missed their first 34
downtown there's a sound spinning and
[Applause]
strong but how about the big fella
he can handle and he can spin and spin
some more back to the middle over Ibaka
using that link and the Thunder we love
the spinners for all runners 15 to 3
see what Whiteside paid him soon
Whiteside with another stellar
protection of the rim that's his second
block your pocket drives him Whiteside
does it again a body Sonics huge
advantage there on the interior he took
advantage of Whiteside early thank to it
right now Whiteside some late work for
the heat got him started in the first
quarter just about you in the tunnel
vision you have to go where everyone
else is and how to try to get them going
Whiteside cool talks his way to the
paint oh he does it for a ferocious slam
dunk for the 2-3 zone trying to protects
us on for picking up anymore foul
Whiteside he is just pulling the strings
to score or to set up his teammates this
time get Big H involved Haywood eight on
the shot clock
that's why time against Gorky sharing
the spin ever slain
[Applause]
now Whiteside looked at Jiang it's a
green light on the office in a home
where he can spin back to the middle
he's got great timing here and then the
strong finish a one-point Heat lead
almost two minutes in there comes a sign
against Thomas Bryant got deep for the
looking ladder game at 70 in finish left
third quarter here in Miami McGruder
down the lane Whiteside hammered it down
on the shot clock for the heat again so
much improves Denver defense first two
shots back there third over Whiteside
slam
tied at 73 a minute 18 left in the third
he slapped that one into the seats
lovey was hoping for the best white over
of a dozen points in seven boards
these are down by 2030 outside oh my
hammer time in Milwaukee
watch this finish how strong boom he
came from so hard right up over the
basket there no questions Jack's been a
big part of the heats best attributes
near death oh how that bad a Winslow
pitch and a Whiteside flush
he and his partner montrezl harrell
number one and number four school
[Applause]
large outstretched right hand nice lot
by Tyler Johnson the first rebound of
tonight's game he spent good rebounding
from the point guard position lob first
shot two scores in a row for white shag
he has 12 down 6 for 8 shooter D -
where's Tyler Johnson fell down and fell
out of his sneaker he's just now getting
back into the offensive that great pets
weight snuck it in there and Whiteside
smash through his second dunk by Adele
dating a death and when he take it back
Tyler Johnson means Johnson rocks for
Whiteside that is the fifth dunk of the
game for a son the paint for Miami
they're finding him on that cut Vonleh
getting hung up trying to show leaving
him open block a left-handed spanked
into the seats by Hassan white 7 and
watch other bases white abalone at the
steal by Joseph Jackson steals it right
back and
that first corner here there's a loose
ball situation and Tyler able to get it
back down to his son who is able to get
ahead of the field there and that's a
crusher
again you have to see both the ball and
your man will not allow any kind of
backups Whiteside with a two-handed dunk
115 points now inserted in terms of
layman has given them has given my aunt
me problems and right side again giving
them problems inside and we defend white
side how do we keep them off the glass
and Miami has come in far in John Reston
good solid stream by shot basketball for
Miami Jay rich off the dribble forcing
Willie cauley-stein to rotate that
leaves the rim open for the two hands
crushing yeah Fi not employing it till
the third quarter you do not give the
Kings a chance to go over it at halftime
and make adjustments so once that gets
the dust as crowded in find Simmons
Jonathan Simmons rejected by Whiteside
Boston this is just great defensive read
for Shaka Smart when Shaco is at
Virginia Commonwealth
[Music]
laterz live Whiteside snitches at home
with a good screen too loud
waiters to turn the corner on the help
defender run out to do a whole flight
control them
he gotta get better shots going to the
basket wait right side how's that for a
better shot 29 for a son one shot is
played Wilson's coming off the bench for
BAM to deep centers both have been
kicked in the elbow block Wade and
Whiteside hammers it down son Whiteside
throw down off the offensive board the
surprise element of it has been very
effective for both teams today prettiest
play of the game Richardson to the young
man out of Gastonia North Carolina he's
doing it in his own backyard in the
paint force in the defense and Kaminsky
to react he draws the defense Kevin I'm
sorry's is it staying to help on him and
that allows a Sun rolling to the rim to
have the easy catch and finish block the
white side smashing great assist for
Winsley to the number 15 I'm a pitchfork
Abaddon right side with a terrific block
that's big-time hustle for a son driving
kick actions not working you Kemp to get
to the rim you're not getting anything
at the rim because the shot blockers are
there they're so long White's up
speaking along and strong the first
round of 2013 was of Miami sweep it
route to a second straight at the eggs I
[Applause]
see hammered that down with both hands
bleeding last night's win over
Philadelphia their five straight wins
have come by an average of 17 points
again
Whiteside from laid that was beautiful
continues to grow and materialize wait
fooling the defense their possession
matters in a game like this one way
dragon finds Whiteside again I love a
Wade why
is clicking 8 points for whites I can
the shooter going over the top and
here's just a gorgeous draw three
different defenders buying in on the
heat drive and time Friday in Jax and
the Fox Sports untrue four on the shot
clock
Johnson locks for Whiteside question
come up with his first pumpkin smash of
the night is Jonah Bouldin at desire
Smith white zags there is Thor fly this
is the Whiteside from three years ago
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content